what drives me to keep perfecting my
craft is i
got into such a great craft that you can
never perfect it
so it's always a dangling carrot you
know it's so mathematical and so
down to the gram of how a pizza turns
out the heat is so scientific it's like
a science project every time you're
making a pizza and i just think it just
became something that
i can chase forever
[Applause]
[Music]
hey it's nicole russell i'm gearing up
for peace awards season three but first
i gotta take you back to where it all
started my home in rockaway queens
[Music]
when i started making pizza i never made
it for myself it became something that
kind of soothed me through a difficult
time my sister was ill i just lost all
of my belongings everything in a storm
but i never really made it for myself i
always made it so my sister and i could
have something to talk about and bond
over
the idea of me selling a pizza wasn't my
idea i had construction workers working
on my house and i just offered them
pizza to be kind
and they started buying the pizza for me
it was never my idea to start doing this
if if they didn't ask me to buy it i
don't think i would ever
thought of it
i have to say the rockaway community
supported me hardcore they wanted to
know if this girl could make pizzas it
was like there's this lady she's down in
auburn and she makes good pizza and they
had to find out
when you describe rockaway to people
they say you live in far far far far far
rockaway and i'm like that's right i
live in far rockaway however it's kind
of cool because it's still accessible to
the city
but
you still have like a
suburban kind of lifestyle a little bit
where it's more chill more zen like if
you wanted zen you could walk up the
block but if you wanted action you could
walk up the block if you know what i
mean
[Laughter]
we're in the boardwalk in my hometown
rockaway beach
and i had the best life growing up out
here
this is the best part of new york you
know imagine being in new york city and
you got a beach right up the block it's
just nothing beats it nothing beats it
i never used to have pizza at the at the
beach because my mom she would pack a
bag you know we're old school she's like
pizza i got your pizza you know like
eddie murphy with hamburger i got
mcdonald's
and you're like this is not mcdonald's
well my mother was like that too she you
know made everything for us
okay we're down to far rockaway i'm at
my favorite place so i grew up eating
pizza
gino's
on 20th for those who know they know
gino's is the best pizza in rockaway for
a long time i don't know if there's a
better pizza now besides me
let me know so i got what i used to
always get after school a plain slice
extra cheese and a grape soda welch's
grape if everybody knows but today a
crush will do you know what i'm saying
but yeah
i'm in for a walk away my old stomping
grounds
feels good to be back
[Music]
you know competing against chefs on
pizza wars has really helped me to be
better because
you know sometimes you can live in a
bubble i always learn something new and
i always pick up a new technique i
always pick up a new idea i always pick
up different flavors so i think that
again it's always going to be a matter
of chasing that carrot because even with
the the contestants it's like oh i
didn't even think of that you know what
i mean and i'm always constantly growing
and being better
but i wanna be
the top i wanna be a great pizza maker i
want to be the best in the world
so get ready season three of peace
awards is coming and you know i'm in it
to win
i'm nicole i'm so happy to see you again
it's been so long i'm so excited
you hate deep dish i [ __ ] hate it yo
mama
this is really a babbage pizza though i
finished this i'm still hungry i want to
keep eating i'm starving i popped my
lactate i'm ready to go for the rest of
the day oh yeah
thank you for having me i couldn't be
more excited to be making pizza with you
today
it's harder than your sister's ass some
squirrels just because my blood type is
ragu that's why you're saying that do
you like caviar i do not like caveats
[Music]
looks like some michelin star how you
doing
my price went up yesterday's price is
not today's price
[Music]